hi everybody are you going to add
thunderous applause in right now
well actually no we're going to add uh
sort of a wind growing across
it blowing across the prairie and the
sound of a single tumbleweed
could i if i could put in a request for
what sounds like a just a standing
ovation of just
just elation okay it'll be that
or crickets we have we have a cricket
sound we've really wanted to try
recently so
let me figure out we're gonna figure it
out but i'll i'll do
something to make you feel real happy i
promise it's nice to see you because
it's a breath of life normalcy because
you know when you're doing these zoom
things in your life it's usually the
same bunch of people you don't really
see anybody new
yeah i know fact that i don't look at
you right now i feel so happy
no me too i actually i feel like i'm
getting my dose of zach brath which
sounds dirty but it's not
i feel i feel i'm always happy to see
you
and yeah you're right we're we're all
living first of all how are you doing
during quarantine
you you seem like you're usually such a
peppy person how are you
i'm i'm glad i'm a little mad i'm sure
like everyone there's been there's been
phases where
i'm i'm i'm like oh this is great we
don't have to do anything
and then then i have phases where i
start to go just insane
yeah yeah if you're anything like me i'm
i alternate between
seeing the silver lining of oh this is
kind of nice and then i swing to the
other side and i kill and kill again
i just i just i i i'm exercising a lot
because the only way i can stay
mentally sane is to exercise like cardio
so um i i i do think that uh i do think
this whole thing is going to
ironically make me in really good shape
so wait what kind of exercise are you
doing in your home
spinning on a peloton bike because i
thought you know when's the next time
i'm ever going to go to a gym so i need
to get one of those
now um so you're pretty religious about
the peloton
i do i do it five days a week just
because um in endorphins wise it makes
me feel
slightly something a little bit like
happiness for about
a half hour afterwards here's my issue i
don't know if you had this issue
but when i was doing the peloton for a
bit and it didn't matter if it was a
woman or a man
but because it was covid i started to
feel like i was having a relationship
with them
i really i started to feel like it's
time you know i need my time with
britney right now or i need my time with
with uh with chris and um you know it's
funny you get loyal to some of the
teachers and then you're like
well i i don't want to upset so and so
but i think i might
i think i might try a class with this
person and then you feel like
i feel like i need to write them a
letter and say it's time i saw someone
else on peloton
which is not just not a good thing